one time I had a Belgian waffle that had
chocolate drizzled on it and that was in
Belgium and that's it well it's in
Spanish you a K date you stuff ooh
I picture being in a South American
countryside like a old like brick house
there's something about this chocolate
taking back your childhood I'm gonna
guess it from El Salvador Argentina
Mexico
Oh Oh dark chocolate this hid like a
whole new dimension when I bite into it
and vision the rainforest with the birds
gonna flying around people wearing
lederhosen Germany Germany Poland
resilient oh I'm close of course
ah you're playing mind games with me oh
my gosh this is a good one cuz like a
little design on it mm-hmm
it has some kind of like weird filling
inside hey Zanna this makes you think of
like a mountaintop little like yodeling
putt is definitely for Germany Italy
France it's so peaceful over there it's
in there chocolate you could taste the
freedom in the chocolate Gold Sun every
bar talkative golden ticket oh my god
what is that picture jail the place is
hot the place is swampy oh I was gonna
say Vietnam Saigon I'm so pissed that
it's a Vietnam I'm just thinking with my
gut on my palate
[ __ ] Apple lumps
oh no that looks fun that's like
chocolate and bubblegum like if they had
a beautiful child in South Africa Brazil
Australia New Zealand what Wow
I got a book of fights New Zealand it's
my favorite chocolate by far is the
pineapple New Zealand a pineapple up to
Swift's the Switzerland one New Zealand
pineapple of the Swiss one the
Venezuelan one was definitely my
favorite I'm still eating it right now I
think chocolate seems to be a universal
language that everybody can appreciate
chocolates the best no matter where it
comes from so everybody just doing what
you do it and make chocolate